c'est pauvre, s'il vous plaît, passez par ici et
merci,
cher Ailish, il est difficile pour moi de croire
que vous avez lu ceci à des milliers de kilomètres à
travers la mer.
tu danses pour moi j'ai rencontré quelqu'un
un gars italien Tony m'a aidé à
sentir que j'ai une vie ici que je n'avais
pas avant de le rencontrer j'ai dit mon
costume sous les vêtements
je suis
un autre très blessé tu veux rentrer à la maison
comment  c'est pour vous si je rentrais chez moi et que j'avais
peur que tout le monde revienne Hailey
's c'est Jim Farrell c'est un grand
plaisir de vous rencontrer
vous avez des plages à Brooklyn ce n'est pas
la même chose alors Jim Farrell est sur est le
piège pour quelqu'un que j'avais imaginé  une
vie différente pour moi quelle est ta
vie ici pourrait être tout aussi bien mieux
Tony je veux que tu saches que
je veux que tu restes ici